speaking in louisville on monday night
president from slammed former San
Francisco 49ers quarterback colin
kaepernick who made an enormous
production out of kneeling for the
national anthem last season Trump
recounted an article he'd read he stated
quote NFL owners don't want to pick him
up because they don't want to get a
nasty tweet from Donald Trump I said if
I remember that one I'm going to report
it to the people of Kentucky because
they like it when people actually stand
for the American flag this isn't good
actually it's quite bad that's not
because Kaepernick doesn't deserve
criticism this is a fellow who wore
socks depicting police officers is pig
who thinks the same America that has
made him rich and famous for being a
one-shot talent is deeply racist in
horrible NFL teams are reticent to pick
Kaepernick up not just because he's a
headache but because he's flamed out as
a football player but the President of
the United States should not be in the
business of bullying businesses into
fire in particular employees or even
being perceived to do so that's scary
imagine of President Obama had
celebrated Mozilla Firefox firing former
CEO Brendan ice over his support for
traditional marriage conservatives would
have been outraged and rightly so this
isn't even Trump celebrating the
predictable results of making deeply
stupid political stand it's been
celebrating his own impact on creating
consequences for people who aren't even
in a political business yes NFL owners
are right to shun Kaepernick but Trump
certainly isn't right to involve himself
in pressuring owners to do so through
his own twitter feed i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
oh so much to get through today we're
going to get to president Trump putting
the screws to house Republicans and
Senate Republicans in order to get them
to buy into his trump care we'll get to
all of that we will also get to all of
the fallout from yesterday on Trump
Russia will get to the fallout on the on
the leaks well guess we'll get to all of
that but first we have to say thank you
to our advertisers are over at
ziprecruiter com so if you're somebody
who is looking to fill in employment
position and you don't want to post on
200 job sites and then wait for all of
the returns to roll in and sift through
them ziprecruiter com helps you out you
can post your job to all of those job
sites with a single click including
Facebook and Twitter you can find
candidates in any city in our industry
nationwide you post once you watch your
qualified candidates roll into
ziprecruiter is easy to use interface
enough to juggle emails or call to your
office you can screen candidates you can
write them and you can hire the right
person incredibly quickly that's why
it's used by Fortune 100 companies it's
why we here as a daily wire are
beginning to use it right now my
listeners can post jobs on ziprecruiter
for free by going to ziprecruiter com
flash daily wire that ziprecruiter calm
/ daily wire and make sure that you try
it because that means that you can post
it for free ziprecruiter calm / daily
wire as somebody who has employed lots
of people in the past and had to sift
through tons and tons of resumes on a
personal level and deal with incoming
phone calls to jangle the phone off the
hook when phones had hook it is much
better to have a process like a
ziprecruiter calm they make it quick
they make it easy they make it fast and
obviously it's cheap right now if you go
to ziprecruiter calm / daily wire you
can post your job for free and fill that
job alrighty so here we are and Donald
Trump has gotten himself in trouble for
yet another day but I want to begin with
a bigger story then everything that's
happening with the wiretapping and the
Russia connections and the leeks and all
that we'll get to all that in just a
second I want to talk about the latest
developments on the hill the thing that
I think is going to have more impact
than any of those things on president
Trump's presidency and that is how this
health care bill goes down so right now
president Trump is on the hill
threatening people according to MJ Lee
over at CNN the White House gave a
message to senators yesterday the
legislation is done they're not going to
be any more changes according to Michael
E Michael E is the senator from Utah
stanch conservative somebody who really
leaves and the principles of the
Constitution really doesn't like Trump
care because he says it's Obamacare
light and now the White House saying no
more changes first off it is important
to note that there are alternatives to
what is being done here Trump and Ryan
are basically saying that there are no
alternatives to what is being done here
there are two alternatives one is just
repeal Obamacare without a replacement
and then replace it piecemeal you can do
that with a straight Republican vote but
Tom Price is the Secretary of Health and
Human Services he's already come out and
he says that's not a possibility they're
not to vote for it which just shows you
that Republicans were lying to you for
years lying to you for years they
weren't promising you that they were
going to replace Obamacare with
something that was Obamacare light they
weren't promising you there weren't
going to be any effects they were going
to be there were going to be no effects
from appealing Obamacare they promised
you they were going to repeal Obamacare
and now Tom Price is telling you they
don't have the boat Paul lines is the
same thing to just repeal the damn thing
so instead of just repealing it we have
to go through this whole rigmarole where
we put together an omnibus package bill
a 120-page bill with tons of regulations
that are going to be attached to it that
is really a crappy bill and it's a
crappy bill for a number of reasons the
only good thing about the bill is the
shifting away from need-based Medicaid
aid from the feds to the states toward a
block grant from the feds to the States
ten billion a year for ten years if you
think however that Congress is going to
hold to those structures you're out of
your mind okay Congress is going to have
that block grant it's going to apply for
about five years and then there's gonna
be a lot of complaints at the state
level and Congress is going to up the
amounts of the block around how do I
know that's going to happen because
that's what's happened with every single
federal program ever created for the
benefit of states it always expands in
size and scope that's just how these
things work that's on the good side okay
on the bad side you've got a bunch of
tax credits for health care which is
basically just a new entitlement program
you have the fact that it keeps in place
all of the Obamacare regulations on
insurance companies or at least the vast
bevy of them it doesn't actually do what
Trump promised during the campaign it
doesn't end the the state lines that
prevent insurance companies from
competing across state lines it doesn't
do any of those things to really really
bad bill but that's not stopping Trump
Trump is pushing hard and the reason
Trump is pushing hard is because this is
a no lose proposition for Trump at this
point Trump is pushing hard because he
doesn't have the patience to actually go
through a negotiation so if you didn't
just want to repeal if you wanted to
repeal in a place there's something else
you can do you could push as the
original
as the original sort of bill you could
push a very conservative bill and then
you could negotiate with the Senate
inside the house you put up your ideal
bill and then you negotiate your opening
position is the position for which you
are negotiating right you wouldn't start
with what Paul Ryan did which is he
negotiated against himself the House
Republicans negotiate against themselves
they created what they thought was a
bill that could pass through Congress
but it's not going to pass them Congress
specifically because whatever the bill
is the first put up is subject to
negotiation and everybody wants input so
what you really want to do if you're
going to do this right is you put up a
bill that your base agrees with and then
you have your solidified your base and
then you move towards something that
more people can agree with that's what
you would do but Trump doesn't have the
patience for prolonged negotiations nor
does he have the policy expertise to
actually speak about a prolonged
negotiation so instead they decided they
were going to fast-track this thing have
Paul Ryan write up a bill that he
thought could pass put it in front of
Trump have Trump ran it through that was
basically the plan here and now Trump is
in a position where he's ramming through
a bill he doesn't fully understand he
doesn't get it the reason you can tell
he doesn't get it is when he speaks
publicly about the bill he's still
making promises that do not apply to
this bill he's still saying things like
nobody's going to get thrown off their
health insurance okay there are people
on Medicaid who are not going to be on
Medicaid anymore if this plan goes
forward so I never thought that that
should be a promise then the Republican
makes the fact is that it's not
government's job to keep you on health
insurance it's your job to go out and
buy your own health insurance and it's
the government's job to get out of the
way so the competition ensures that the
price is lower for health insurance and
the quality is higher for health
insurance doesn't matter Trump right now
is trying around this thing through in
typical Trump fashion he apparently said
to a bunch of House members we won't
have these clouds if we don't get this
done he's talking about all of the all
of the crowds that he's speaking to as
though those crowds are are in any way
indicative of the level of public
support for this plan the polls show
this plan is highly highly unpopular
it's really unpopular according to nate
silver who's quoting all of the polls
right now and yes polls still matter
it's not we don't live in Bill Mitchell
world where polls don't matter polls
still matter just because they were off
on the state level does not mean that
polls are now completely out the window
ok here is the the favorable numbers on
the Republican health care bill Fox News
it has the favorable number on Trump
care
thirty-four percent fifty-four percent
opposed morning consult has it at plus
11 that is the only poll that has an
impossible territory yougov CBS News has
it it 29 below yougov Huffington Post
has it 21 below public policy polling
has it 25 below the average 16 below
thirty percent support forty-seven
percent oppose nobody likes this bill
conservatives Democrats nobody likes
this bill now Obamacare had a 40-percent
favorable rating and a 49-percent
unfavorable rating when it was passed
that means that this is significantly
less popular than that and Democrats
lost 63 seats in Congress because of
Obamacare so if you want to hold the
house this is not the way to do it this
is not the way that you hold the house
by the way only thirteen percent of
Trump supporters strongly support this
they think that it's paul ryan's plan
and they do not strongly support this
but Trump is coming in hard because he
knows that if this whole thing falls
apart he's not going to get blamed he's
going to be seen as a good soldier and
the person who is going to be blamed in
the end is going to be you gots it Paul
Ryan so Paul Ryan is going out there and
he's saying that Donald Trump is here to
close the deal guys Donald Trump is here
and he's going to close the hilt what he
does best that is Ryan trying to kiss
from SAS it is not going to work it is
not going to work the sycophant c is
going to maybe drive Trump to support
the Ryan plan but the Ryan plan goes
down in flames if he thinks the Trump is
going to be there for the incoming fire
he is totally wrong this is it's Ryan's
butt on the line not Trump's here mark
Meadows is one of the representatives
who opposes the bill he's been saying he
doesn't back the bill and Trump is
targeting him directly which is really
ridiculous mean we're now targeting
Republicans for not voting for a bill
that's not conservative enough if this
bus if this whole thing falls apart the
results are going to be disastrous for
conservatives particularly Trump will
likely blame Ryan who will likely shift
more to the economic populism and
nationalism of Steve benen and away from
Reince Priebus I'm not around for this
an amount of Paul Ryan fan but I'd
rather have the economic program of Paul
Ryan and rides Priebus and the economic
program of steve van and Trump Trump
tends to be more on band inside anyway
on this sort of stuff you could see very
easily Donald Trump moving away from
working with House and Senate
Republicans at all and just crossing the
aisle and working with Democrats on his
populist to economic program if this
thing flames out because he's going to
blame Ryan for anything
falls apart here is going to blame Ryan
Priebus for anything that falls apart
here you can see him doing the okay now
I'm gonna swivel from the middle I tried
working with you guys I tried to do it
your way I tried to your way and now I'm
not going to do it anymore we saw
tendencies like this from Trump during
the campaign he said he didn't care if
the Republicans held the Senate because
maybe he'd be able to get things done
with Democrats more easily he has a
tendency not to really like the the
quote unquote establishment of the party
and right now if he goes down in flames
over the spill he's going to blame them
and he can turn away from them and
that's going to be really is going to
have really negative ramifications for
people who want to see some conservative
governance because you're not going to
get conservative governance between
Trump band and the Democrats in the in
the house and the Senate is interesting
i was listening to another podcast there
there's some top Democrats who do a
podcast positive America which is an
interesting Cod cast I like to listen to
to get you know kind of what Democrats
are thinking and they were saying that
they are upset with Trump not because
Trump is backing Trump care so much but
because Trump care isn't Trumpy enough
they want Trump to swivel toward the
economic nationalist populism of Steve
benen and they say openly there might be
a political realignment in store if
Trump does exactly that Trump sees that
same opportunity so this could be the
precursor to a solid move now maybe
not maybe maybe Trump sticks with the
program maybe from maintains
conservative you know conservative
policies like he's been doing about
seventy percent so far maybe he
maintains that even if this bill goes
down I think that's doubtful I think
that's doubtful okay with that said
Donald Trump did have a very bad day
yesterday it's not even to be his worst
day of the week if this bill goes down
on Thursday it's supposed to be voted on
in the house on Thursday wouldn't be the
first time that house leadership has
presented a bill that went down and
plans happened regularly under John
Boehner yesterday was a bad day for
Trump because there were basically two
stories neither of them good for Trump
one was Jim call me the the FBI director
who is not particularly competent speaks
out of seats out of line affair but he
was in front of the House Intelligence
Committee yesterday and he said that
Donald's from sweets about wiretapping
they just weren't i'ma call me talking
to Adam chef of California director
Comey was the president's statement that
Obama had his wires captain Trump Tower
a true statement with respect to the
president's tweets about alleged
wiretapping directed at him by the
prior administration I have no
information that supports those tweets
and we have looked carefully inside the
FBI the Department of Justice has asked
me to share with you that the answer is
the same for the Department of Justice
and all its components the department
has no information that supports those
tweets as you understand the term
McCarthyism do you think President Obama
or the FBI was engaged in such conduct
I'm not going to try and characterize
the tweets themselves all I can tell you
is we have no information that supports
them director Comey or a good lawyer can
you make out a great case that President
Obama wiretap mr. Trump's phones just
part of the election in light of the
fact you have said there's no evidence
of that all I can say is what I said
before that we don't have any
information that supports those tweets
okay so you know any keep saying it over
and over and over the Democrats keep
hammering at home over and over and over
there is no evidence that Trump was
wiretap by Obama now here's what
actually happened in all likelihood by
all the available reports basically
there are 50 warrants out on a bunch of
Russians and those FISA warrant allowed
the government's listen in on all of
these Russians who were apparently doing
business with Americans are talking to
americans and a bunch of Trump
associates were swept up in those
wiretaps so in other words you know
let's say that let's say that Austin or
a Russian agent which is not implausible
and the and the government decided to
put a wiretap on Austin and I called
Austin up well now i'm on the wiretap
okay that's what was actually wiretapped
and that's how Mike Flynn got caught up
in this conversation now we're going to
get to the leaking portion of this in a
second because that is also a real
scandal but it is not a real thing that
Obama orders direct wire tap on Trump
the reports that were promulgated by
heat street that FISA had the FISA
warrant had been issued for Trump Tower
that was debunked yesterday by I think
it was Mike Rogers who's the head of the
National Security Agency none of this is
good for Trump Trump could have after
the original tweet said look I was
speaking figuratively I was speaking
broadly what I really meant was that
there was obvious government
surveillance of people in my campaign
because people in my campaign were
talking to the Russians and it's just
ridiculous that information about that
stuff is being leaked to the press
that's accurate that's good but because
Trump two things Trump only reads the
headlines he never reads below the
headline and to trump always doubles
down and that means that he created
entire big problem for himself in which
he looks foolish in which he looked like
he made this case that is
unsubstantiated and that is a disaster
for him because again it goes to
credibility his approval ratings are
already low he's going to need that
credibility when it comes time to ram
through legislation if you're going to
make the case and Republicans they need
to get on board with Trump care and that
you got the American people behind you
you actually have to be able to show
data showing that the American people
are behind you and trust you and right
now he's undermining that trust and
we'll talk in a second about you know
more of the fallout from this because
it's not good for president Trump if you
want him to be successful you need him
to stop with the Twitter honestly his
administration would be much better off
if he would just stop with the Twitter
altogether I know people who are fans of
his don't like that idea the fact is
that he's doing himself more harm than
good with the Twitter account at this
point if he wants to be sporadic in his
use of it targeted and he'd use of it
that's one thing he is not he's a
blunderbuss okay we have to say hello
and thank you to our advertisers over at
dstl decom so best jeans I own dstl
d.com premium denim and that it's
distilled you get ten percent off your
first pair when you go to GST LD calm /
men these aren't great jeans they are
much cheaper than the genes that are
going to get at some sort of premium
outlet they are you know but really
cheap jeans the number one starts to
fall apart after a few washes these
things last and last and last they are
very solid and you don't want to break
the bank and these are really well
priced in there well under a hundred
dollars you can get a pair of jeans at
dstl decom 565 box I mean there's a
really really good genes they look good
they are comfortable they're not going
to fall apart on you and the reason
they're able to bring them to you so
cheap is because their direct consumer
they're not filing it through some sort
of retailer and by the way if you try
them out and you don't like them they
will ship them to you for free and give
you free returns until you find the
perfect pair soon enough to worry about
they should be a pair of jeans they
don't fit now you're stuck with them you
can ship them back until you get the
right one they also have outerwear
they've leather jackets and t-shirts and
more and the same principle everything
is much cheaper than it would be if you
went to a store DST LG calm / been
really good looking clothes terrific
jeans dstl drm distilled calm / men get
ten percent off your first pair ten
percent off your first pair of jeans at
DST LD calm / been okay so it wasn't
just James Comey who's slapping around
Trump on the
this from wiretapping allegations again
all Trump had to do was tell the truth
instead Donald Trump has a very
rudimentary understanding of how the
news works he reads the headlines he
determines what he wants to determine
from the headlines he puts it out there
and then he triples down on it and goes
mole hunting on the basis of a fantasy
that is only in his head it's just dumb
it just don't forget about whether you
know you think that Obama's a bad guy or
not I think Obama is a bad guy forget
about whether you think that Obama
intelligence people are leaking bad
things about Toronto I think they are
right now and I'll get to those leaks in
just a second Trump needs to stop with
this crap it makes them look stupid
here's Mike Rogers to the National
Security Administration saying that
Trump you know trotting out this theory
that the British were behind some sort
of tapping of him he said that to
utterly ridiculous did you have a
request that your counterparts and gchq
should wiretap mr. Trump on behalf of
President Obama no sir nor would I that
would be expressly against the construct
of the five eyes agreement that's been
in place for decades and the five eyes
are some of our closest intelligence
partners and Britain Britain is one of
them yes sir have you seen any evidence
that anyone else in the Obama
administration made such a request no
sir and again my view is the same as
director Comey I've seen nothing on the
NSA side that we enjoy he noted it was
appointed by Donald Trump so his own guy
is saying right here that this is
nonsense Devin Nunez who's a Republican
on the House Intelligence Committee he
debunked that story that said there was
a FISA warrant for Trump Tower said
there is no FISA warrant for Trump Tower
his administration no evidence of any
wiretapping of Trump Tower no no there
was no FISA warrant that I'm aware of to
trump to tap Trump Tower and that's
after you receive this information
that's accurate ok so again that whole
thing it's really dumb I wish that Trump
would just stick to the facts again this
has been my critique of Trump sins all
the way through the campaign since the
beginning if you sacrifice truths in
favor of power you end up with neither
power nor truth that's what's happening
right now tendencies for untruth come to
tend to come back and bite you we're
going to get next into the Russia
connection scandal and into the leaks
which i think is the biggest scandal of
all the Democrats I want to talk about
that one we will talk about that one but
you have to go to daily wire calm for
that daily where dr. on me become a
subscriber right now eight dollars a
month become one of the thousands in
South
and thousands of people who are
subscribing into daily wire.com for
eight bucks a month right now to get an
annual subscription you get a free
signed copy of the Amazon best-selling
book so you know nearly 100,000 copies i
think at this point reasons to vote
democrat a comprehensive guide signed by
Michael moles endorsed by yours truly as
the most thorough book that I have ever
seen on Democratic ideology and the
reasons to support it reasons to vote
Democratic comprehensive guide by
Michael mole gene get that for for free
signed when you become an annual
subscriber over at daily wire.com so
check that out or you can listen to the
rest of the podcast later now you can
watch the rest of the podcast by the way
that's one of the benefits of being a
daily water subscriber you can watch the
rest of the podcast live be part of the
mailbag which we do in a couple of days
and get clay Evans podcast live watch
that I know I keep getting emails about
the Shapiro store I promise I swear it
is coming it is coming and it's not
coming just like Obamacare repeal was
coming it's actually coming okay it's
going to come and it will happen shortly
if you don't want to subscribe right now
but you're still wanna listen to the
rest of the show go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud and give us a listen over
there we are the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
you